heute abend hier bei bild frau
leutheuser-schnarrenberger impfpflicht
da müssen wir auch über die
verantwortung der politik sprechen und
über die versprechen die es über monate
ja eigentlich über zwei jahre gegeben
hat das kommt nicht und dann kommt das
eben genau doch das ist natürlich noch
male zusätzlicher reiz also welche
verantwortung tragen sie trägt die
politik für diesen ja muss man sagen
wortbruch
also es hat ja glaube ich in allen
parteien zu beginn der pandemie
2020 wo er die heutige szenerie und
entwicklung alle nicht vorhergesehen
haben keiner hat von einer vierten welle
bei der ersten welle gesprochen
da war ganz eindeutig also impfpflicht
wollen wir nicht haben wir nicht für
masern hatte man sie für kinder aber
vorher auch schon einem anderen kontext
beschlossen so und jetzt haben wir jetzt
schon eine geänderte situation aber ich
glaube gerade was eben auch an
einschätzungen gesagt wurde man kann
nicht einfach so salopp hingehen sich
hinstellen und sagen so und jetzt hau
war hier mal die allgemeine impfpflicht
ganz schnell durch hensel da kommt ja
fast jeden tag damit wir kommen an
dieser impfpflicht nicht vorbei und ich
glaube so
kann man gerade das nicht erreichen was
er gesagt hat nämlich diejenigen die
nicht zu den radikalen gehören denen nur
der anlass wichtig ist aber nicht der
inhalt kennen identität bewegung dritte
weg das sind die extremisten die
erreichen war da alle nicht mit aber die
die sorge angst haben auch nicht
vertrauen haben in politik auch in den
impfstoff kein vertrauen haben da gibt
es immer noch genug die bringen war
komplett in der ecke wenn wir jetzt zu
tun als sei die allgemeine impfpflicht
jetzt das credo was alle politiker
vertreten und deshalb ist auch glaube
ich muss ihm anlass japan häusern vag
und man muss jetzt mal debattieren sagen
sie damit herr söder trägt auch dazu bei
dass die stimmung umso aufgeheizter
aufgeladener ist
nein ich nein ich glaube es bringt
nichts einzelnen politikern jetzt eine
schuld zuzuweisen an einer entwicklung
okay sagen weil es aber auch heißen art
und weise wie er die impfpflicht bringen
wie er die impfpflicht thematisiert bei
jeder gelegenheit nach dem motto alles
andere greift nicht aber das wissen wir
doch heute noch gerade wir sind doch in
diesem prozess verschärfen da maßnahmen
und da kann ich nicht heute zu tun als
sei die impfpflicht der einzige weg raus
aus der pandemie und dass das ist wasser
auf die mühlen derjenigen die wirklich
hier versuchen mit aller macht ein
argument gegen den staat zu finden ist
das so herberger ihrer erfahrung nach
bei ihm vor der haustür in grimma auch
in sachsen ist dass das ding was denn
was der der funke sozusagen ist der
tropfen der es zum überlaufen bringt die
impfpflicht
nein aber ich will mal kurz an die
vorräte noch anknüpfen und zwar nicht zu
unterschätzen
unterschätzen ist natürlich das internet
als medium das in möglichkeiten gegeben
die aber noch gar nicht und zum das
ganze hat ja auch eine entwicklung
genommen und aus meiner erfahrung
braucht so es gab erst eine allgemeine
unzufriedenheit mit dem management
insgesamt da hat sie eine demokratie
nicht ganz einfach weil die minister
haben sich teilweise widersprochen die
im mps haben sich widersprochen und das
hat natürlich eine gewisse verwirrung
gesorgt auch bei brighton geschichten
die eigentlich im fällig waren und dann
ist das ganze verkommen zu seinem auto
abenteuerspielplatz für alle die
irgendwie unzufrieden waren sich mal
profilieren wollten die haben das thema
genutzt jetzt hat es die gefährliche
phase erreicht das eben sich dann
bewusst politische extreme gruppen das
zunutze machen als plattform und das
halte ich für äußerst gefährlich also
wir haben ein dreistufiges verfahren
hier erleben müssen leider und es wird
schwer sein das der einzelfall ist der
staat wirklich gefragt und natürlich die
gesellschaft wir haben auch überlegt
immer ob die operation art offenen brief
machen denn ich denke dass 98 prozent
der bevölkerung hier noch mit dem kopf
schütteln wie einige wenige uns hier
eigentlich tagtäglich vorführen nicht
nur ein krimi sondern eigentlich unser
ganzes land und man müsste eigentlich
eine demo machen mit ihrem häufig
gebrauchten begriff wir sind das volk
aber dann wirklich mal als cd
gesellschaft im sinne von wir wissen
dass demokratie was wertvoll ist und wir
lassen uns das von einigen wenigen
lauten nicht kaputt machen